let's go next to our caller from the
nine five one area code who's calling
today from 951 hey David this is Dylan
in California hey Dylan what's going on
I was wondering I know you specifically
talked about how your identify as a
social democrat
not a Democratic Socialist right I was
wondering if you would support
theoretically if Democrats like created
legislation where it gave American
workers a right to purchase the
corporation that they owned that they
work for from the owners mm-hm would you
support legislation for that or would
you consider that like two socialist for
your own political ideologies let me see
if I so you're saying imagine that there
is a company I don't know let's imagine
it's what what kind of a company it's an
accounting firm for example and one
accountant starts an accounting firm and
after a few years they hire a second
accountant and then after a few years
they hire ten more accountants and
twenty accounting assistants and some
administrative staff and they get to 35
employees or something like that
the a year would be that a law would be
passed where if those 34 employees in
other words there's 35 employees
including the owner if the other 34
employees want to buy the company that
the founder of the company would be
forced to sell the company to them is
that what you're suggesting I would be
against that yeah what would be your
reasoning I don't know what basis there
would be for the government coming in
and saying business owners are going to
be forced by statute to sell businesses
they may not want to sell I don't that
that doesn't make any sense to me that's
not something I would push for okay
thanks all right very good thank you I
mean in the same way that it you know I
wouldn't allow the government to say you
have to sell other property of your own
I wouldn't say that the government
should come in and say people have to be
forced to sell a business it's just
that's not my politics okay
I guess to me that sounds like a lot
like us saying that's different than us
regulating corporations and other ways
like how I guess for me is that
different than a thing you can't like
right so wrapped in your hamburgers or
something like that like that us like so
you for do what with your hand like
restaurant like we tell fast-food places
that you can't write you can't sell rat
in your hamburger otherwise the
government is going to come and shut you
down
right yeah government regulate
government regulation of businesses is
based on completely different government
authority than the government mandating
that employers that owners sell their
business to employees would be based on
so I don't think that it's a good
analogy at all um okay I guess I see it
as like a moral argument like really
cleanliness is a value of ours so like
if we you value like like worker
representation and the workplace then
you would give them avenues to better
represent themselves right sure and that
there are a number of ways that that
could be done that stopped short of
mandating that people sell businesses
that they don't they don't want to sell
you know what I mean
doing yeah totally what would what would
be a policy that you would support that
like
adheres that value I'd have to think
about it but it would have to vary
depending on company size because what's
reasonable and practical at small
businesses would differ from medium and
from large but let me think about that a
little bit okay well I'd love sorry
I'd love some content on that appreciate
your show thanks for taking my call okay
great Dylan thank you appreciate the
phone call very much